what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and in this video i
will be breaking down the life of
zenitsu a man who started out as a
wannabe womanizer crybaby with a tragic
past but ended up becoming a true badass
chad and a faithful husband father and
family man a lot of people hated zenitsu
at the beginning of the series and they
found him to be extremely annoying but i
always kind of liked him and i thought
he was funny well my trust in zenitsu
paid off because his heroic struggle
against loss betrayal demons and his own
insecurities made for an absolutely
electrifying character progression so
let's get into it if you guys enjoy our
demonstrate content and you want us to
keep it going just leave a quick like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps with the youtube algorithm and
if you're new to the channel or maybe
you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a quick favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications it is a completely free
but also very important way of directly
supporting this channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror finally this video will
contain demon slayer manga spoilers all
the information about zenitsu's life
from the manga is fair game so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned when we first meet zenitsu he is
one of the four people who passed the
final selection exam for joining the
demon slayer core along with tanjiro
kanao and genya however instead of being
happy that he was one of the few who
managed to successfully pass such a
difficult trial zenitsu was actually
scared about the many dangers that he
will now face in his new life as a demon
slayer he also seems desperate to find a
wife before he potentially loses his
life on his first mission so he tries to
beg a random girl to marry him forcing
tanjiro to intervene zenitsudan asks
tanjiro to protect him until he can find
a wife and get married despite being
only like 16 years old at this point
zenitsu is obsessed with marriage
because he really seems to think that
getting married and starting a family is
an essential part of life and so he
doesn't want to die before he has a
chance to fulfill that goal at this
point tanjuro is wondering what most of
us are wondering if zenitsu is so scared
of dying then why would he decide to
become a demon slayer in the first place
zenitsu explains that sometime in the
past he was tricked by a woman whom he
was infatuated with and she basically
conned him out of all his money he ended
up in massive debt and he was in big
trouble until an old man took pity on
him and paid his debt off this old man
was jigoro kuaijima the former thunder
hashira after paying off zenitz's death
he trained him in the art of
swordsmanship and he was the only person
who ever saw any potential in him
zenitsu grew up without his parents and
he didn't really have anyone in his life
who cared about him he had no guidance
or affection in life everyone he knew
gave up on him except for jigoro so even
though zenitsu is clearly scared of
becoming a demon slayer he wants to
honor his master jigoro by doing that
which he was trained to do protect
humanity from demons i can definitely
understand why people disliked zenitsu
at first although as i said i always
thought that he was funny compared to
all the other demon slayers who are all
strong and seemingly fearless zenith
looks like a total schmuck he appears to
be more interested in finding a wife
than doing his duty he's constantly
complaining about the dangerous nature
of their missions and he just seems to
be weak and useless compared to everyone
else but during the tsuzumi mansion arc
we got our first real insight into
zenitz's true potential and his latent
badassery at one point zenitsu and a
young boy named shoichi are ambushed by
a demon inside the mansion zenitsu is so
frightened that he seemingly passes out
from fear and that seems pretty
consistent with the type of behavior
that we've seen from him up to this
point but then something unexpected
happens as the demon begins his attack
zenitsu suddenly cuts off the demon's
tongue and then absolutely wrecks him
this was such an epic moment that
demonstrated zenitz's true potential but
there's just one problem zenitsu
defeated the demon while sleepwalking so
he wasn't actually conscious when he did
it when he wakes up zenitsu has no idea
what happened and he thinks that the boy
shoiichi was the one who defeated the
demon from this scene we see that
zenitsu really does have incredible
talent and potential as a demon slayer
but it is all buried within his
subconscious at this point in the story
he simply cannot unlock that potential
when he is actually awake he still has
too much baggage and too many
insecurities but as the story continues
so does the progression of zenitz's
character in chapter 33 we get a brief
flashback to zenith's training with
jigoro and we see that despite being a
full-time scaredy-pants crybaby zenitsu
really did want to live up to his
master's expectations and he trained
extremely hard every single day not just
with jigoro but even alone on his own
time he trained to the point that he
barely even slept one day he decided to
climb up a tree to hide from his master
because he thought that if he trains
anymore he will actually die while he
was up on that tree the tree got struck
by lightning and that is when zenitz's
naturally dark hair turned blonde so
yeah zenitz's plan to escape the world
by climbing up a tree didn't exactly
work out but during that flashback we
did learn another thing jigoro really
cared about zenitsu not just as a
disciple but it was almost like zenitsu
was his own grandson and zenitsu even
called him gramps jigoro was basically
the only family that zenitsu had ever
known and this bond that he had with his
master would play a massive role in
zenith's character development
throughout the entirety of the story
this flashback also reveals that during
his training zenitsu only ever managed
to learn one breath of thunder four even
though there are six known forms at this
point in time zenitsu could never learn
more than the first form of thunder
breathing called thunderclap and flash
but instead of berating him his master
jigoro understood zenitsu's predicament
and he told him that if he could only do
one form then he should do his best to
master it completely he should put all
of his effort into developing the
perfect first form and become better at
it than anyone else and that is exactly
what zenitsu strived to do another thing
that is revealed around the same time is
that zenitsu wasn't jigoro's only
disciple jigoro had a second disciple
whose name is later revealed to be
kaigaku kaigaku was an orphan who had a
very tough childhood and he was forced
to become a thief and steal scraps of
food just to survive eventually he was
taken in by jigoro and trained to use
thunder breeding just like zenitsu
except kaigaku was able to master all of
the forms and he was seemingly far
better suited to become jigoro's
successor than zenitsu no one believed
this more fervently than kaigaku himself
and he hated zenitsu for being weak
cowardly and overly familiar with their
master kaigaku often mocked and bullied
zenitsu during their training and for
his part zenitsu hated kaigaku but he
also respected his impressive strength
and swordsmanship skills the fact that
jigoro wanted both of his disciples to
become his successors infuriated kaigaku
who believed that he was far superior to
zenitsu and the more we learn about
kaigaku the more obvious it becomes that
he is a terrible person kaigaku's rough
childhood made him value his own
survival over everything else and he was
even willing to sacrifice the lives of
many other innocent people in order to
preserve his own life he was also
prepared to shamelessly beg and grovel
for his life if he believed that the
situation required it so any talk of him
being an honorable and righteous
successor of jigoro was never anything
more than talk eventually kaigaku's
drive for self-preservation at all cost
drove him to willingly become a demon
and he would ultimately attain the rank
of upper moon 6 after the death of daki
and yutaru the fact that one of his
disciples went on to become a demon was
so humiliating to jigoro that he
committed seppuku with no second in
order to atone for his disciples sins
this revelation absolutely broke
zenith's heart and he vowed to defeat
kaigaku
ultimately gets his chance to confront
his greatest rival inside the infinity
castle and having honed his skills and
confidence for many chapters and also
having brought his subconscious
potential into his waking reality
zenitsu manages to defeat kaigaku using
a new form of thunder breathing called
honoikazuchi no kami at first kaigaku
thinks that jigoro had secretly taught
this technique to zenitsu only because
he liked zenitu more than him but
zenitsu says that no he invented this
new seventh form himself because he
wanted to be able to fight alongside
kaigaku as his equal as kaigaku dies and
zenitsu loses consciousness zenitsu
suddenly finds himself in front of his
old master jigoro at this point zenitsu
is presumably on the doorway to the
afterlife and so he is able to see his
master on the other shore of a river
zenitsu calls out to his master and he
apologizes for how things turned out he
blames himself for the fact that kaigaku
became a demon and he wonders whether
jigoro hates him now but jigoro merely
looks at zenitsu with tears in his eyes
and says i'm proud of you
what a touching moment and what a
fascinating comparison we can make
between zenitsu and kaigaku on the
surface these guys had a very similar
life both were essentially orphans with
no one to turn to and jigoro became the
closest thing that both of them had to
family but while kaigaku let his harsh
past define him and while he dedicated
his entire life to his own
self-preservation no matter the cost
zenitsu recognized that despite his past
hardships there were people out there
like jigoro who truly loved and accepted
him and so even though he was a scared
crybaby who wanted nothing more than a
safe and normal life zenetsu knew that
there were more important things out
there than just preserving his own life
and he knew that there were other people
out there who were worth risking his
life for meanwhile kaigaku was arrogant
selfish and obsessed with his own power
and preservation and so he could never
look past his own narrow interests even
after he found someone who genuinely
cared for him like jigoro he could never
be happy because he always wanted more
power and more recognition this
dichotomy between kaigaku and zenitsu
and the duality of zenitsu's cowardly
and yet honorable character make
zenitsu's ultimate character progression
that much better he didn't start out
strong or brave he was scared he was
weak and he just wanted to run away and
hide but he didn't he learned to push
through the fear and the pain in order
to become a truly admirable warrior and
that is why i absolutely love him as a
character and as far as this whole
wannabe womanizer thing is concerned i
think that his character development in
that sphere of his personality is also
remarkable he starts off so desperate to
find a wife that he's willing to ask a
random girl on the street to marry him
but once he meets nezuko and develops
feelings for her his womanizing
tendencies slowly dissipate whereas most
people were absolutely furious to learn
that tanjiro was trying to protect his
demon sister zenitsu was quick to accept
nezuko and he did his best to protect
her despite the fact that she was a
demon and he was a demon slayer i think
that's an important aspect of zenith's
character that we can't overlook despite
being taught to fear and hate all demons
for his entire life zenetsu didn't give
in to fear and hate when it came to
nezuko he gave her a chance he took time
to know her and eventually he developed
feelings for her and even fought to
protect her he demonstrated his respect
for nezuko many times throughout the
story and he eventually marries her has
children with her and becomes a
committed husband father and family man
he completely abandons all of his
wannabe womanizing as soon as he finds
the right person and he eventually shows
himself to be a true woman respecter i
mean don't forget that even back in the
entertainment district long before his
character fully developed zenitsu was
willing to stand up to daki an upper
demon moon in order to protect one of
the female servants that daki had been
abusing zenitsu took a massive beating
because he wanted to protect this girl
that he had only just met but he still
did it because it was the right thing to
do and that is the story of zenitsu he
is often scared he is often insecure and
he often wants to run away but he pushes
through the fear and he does the right
thing in the end that is why i think
he's a great character a true hero and
an admirable demon slayer oh and he's
also the one who wrote down the exploits
of the demonstr during their fight with
muzon if he hadn't written that book
those of us who live in modern times
never would have known about the demon
slayer story so yeah zenitsu is kind of
a big deal let me know what you guys
think about xenotu and his character
progression down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this demonstrator video
and you want us to keep it going just
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps with
the youtube algorithm and if you're new
to the channel or maybe you watch our
videos but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all if you don't do
that you're still going to miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror i want to give a quick thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma and
kyle salisbury these guys are absolute
mad lads and disciples of lord tuigo
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all other clans including ingrata
algital pate heffa the red-haired fox
hinokamian water the toasted cheek corey
mcgowan the spike lonely the car dylan
isadore spidey life tinnel tungsten
tarkis big buddhist jeremy cummings and
che whitley finally thank you also to
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only gilgamesh steelers on hell
cruise very gucci alicia octor bonnie
parks joanne garcia fat boy games kaido
might be a duck jessica rabbit jeremy
phillips alivania temple king matthew
and demetrius water if you guys enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patreon exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these amazing people oh and if you don't
have a patreon account becoming a
youtube channel member gives you the
same perks as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you